To solve this and compound inequality, let's solve each and inequality
separately. For the first inequality, we add 4 to both sides, then divide by
negative 3, to isolate x. Remember, we divided by a negative so we need to
reverse the inequality sign. So, for this inequality sign, x needs to be less
than negative 3. For the second inequality, we add 1 to both sides, then we
divide by 5. So x is less than or equal to negative 4. We have an AND
inequality, so I want both of these solutions to be true. x needs to taken a
value that works for this inequality and this inequality. So I want to find the
overlap of these 2 regions. Let's look back at our number lines. Here are two
solution regions. x could be less than or equal to negative 4, or x could be
less than negative 3. We have an and inequality, so we want the region of
overlap. So, it's any number, less than or equal to negative 4. That would be
this number line. Nice job if you got that one right.